- You are what you are,
nothing more and nothing less.
Be proud of who you are, no matter,
God made you so you are what you are
and you ain't what you ain't.
See, I was raised in a holler
that didn't even get a
road till like the 50s
and the food we got, we had to raise it.
That's what I was telling them.
When I was four year old
or five, a little kid,
they made a hoe just for our size
to hoe taters in the gardens.
You know what I'm saying?
That's all we got to do
was work in the garden.
And I mean, well, we played
ball and stuff like that,
but we was like...
I was raised in the mountain.
I mean, literally in the mountain.
You know what I'm saying?
I'd love to take you
to where I was raised.
There's a big water fall.
Oh, it's beautiful.
I mean, it is, it's like...
It ain't like the Cumberland Falls,
but it's probably more...
It's even prettier than
that I guess it is.
- But what was it like growing up
in the mountains like that?
You're isolated from
everybody else, right?
- Yeah, but we never got bored.
We just...
We would build us a sled
like in the winter time
and stay out in the snow
and ride sleds till dark.
And we played in the creeks.
We'd dam the creeks up or go
to the falls and swim in it.
You know? I mean, we
always had something to do
even though we had nothing.
Or build like a wooden wagons
and we pretty much didn't get toys
till we were 10; 10 year old.
I believe when I got my first bicycle and
life was hard, but it was good.
- It's a great way for
a kid to grow up, right.
- Right.
- You wouldn't change it, right?
- Oh, no, no.
I loved how I was raised really.
- Tell me about your parents.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Well, my mom and then she
went to Baltimore when I was 12
and I stayed with my
grandma and my grandpa.
And he was like the best
person in the whole world.
- And how much...
How far did you go in school?
- Till my junior year.
That was a bad mistake
dropping out of school though.
It really was.
- Is that your biggest regret?
- Yeah, it is my biggest regret.
'Cause I played basketball.
I was like...
I was a real good ballplayer.
If I had stayed in school
I probably...
I might not even...
Well, I ain't gonna say I'd
probably move, but you know,
I would've had a different life.
You know what I'm saying?
And I left and went to Baltimore
and got there and stayed like
three months and got homesick.
And back to the mountains I come and I...
- I've heard that story a lot
from a lot of people here.
They leave and they come back.
- Yeah, that's what I was telling him.
I got to the bus station at
two o'clock in the morning
and the bus was full.
So he said, "the next
bus is tomorrow at two."
And I just broke down and started crying.
I said "Please man. Let me on this bus
'cause I wanna go home.
I wanna come see my pappaw."
And he said, "well, you
can sit in the floor
or on the steps."
And he made me a little seat
beside his and I rode...
It was a five-hour drive from
Baltimore to Pennsylvania,
but I'd of walked just to get back home.
You know what I'm saying?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. We would go swimming everyday
like up Greasy and up to Bee Rock.
And we just always had fun
but everybody was real
poor where we was raised
as a lot of them was alcoholics.
A lot of times, you couldn't
even get up the holler for 'em
'cause you had passed
five or six in the road
passed out on the way up the holler.
You know what I'm saying?
You'd have to drag them
out of the road to get by
and then half of them
would want to fight you.
But all them old people
are dead now though.
- You're the cousin of Geraldine
who I interviewed a month ago.
- Yeah. Yeah.
My mammaw that raised me
and her mommy are sisters.
I love Geraldine.
- Yeah. It's a rough life here.
- Yeah.
- But that struggle seems to make...
- Yes, see she raised up five
boys pretty much on her own
and I raised three pretty much on my own.
- Where was the father?
Well, he's in and out, but you know...
I didn't want him around too much.
- Yeah. How far did you go in school?
- Till my junior year.
I lacked one year of graduating.
- And you raised three kids?
- Yeah. Three boys.
- And how'd you support yourself?
- I'd work for my uncle, my aunts
just mostly little odd jobs
or go in the mountain and dig roots up.
Dig ginseng.
- So you'd consider
yourself a mountain woman.
- Yeah. Hell yeah.
- There's a lot of mountain men,
but you're a mountain woman.
- I love the mountains. I
was raised in the mountains.
I mean, I go ginsenging.
Well anymore, I'm sort of...
My feet and my heart's bad.
I can't walk like I used to, but yeah,
I'd go sometimes dig
three pounds of 'seng.
what's the most I ever dug
at one time was three pounds.
- Of ginseng?
- Yeah. But every day...
Good money in ginseng
and we'd save it back, like
to live through the winter on.
You know what I'm saying?
Dig you out a root and
like a (indistinct).
- And that's certainly
gotta be hard work, right?
- Yeah, it's hard.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I was ginsenging
up Double Creek one time.
And I seen this...
I thought was a big (indistinct)
I got over there
and there's a copperhead
wrapped around my left leg
and I went to kick it off and when I did,
I jumped and when I jumped
I had leggins on up to
my knees, but I fell.
And when I come up,
I said, "Oh man! I
believe that snake bit me"
and it bit me right an
inch above my leggins.
So, and I ginsenged like
for three hours snake bit.
But when I got to the truck
and took that leggin off,
my leg just blowed up.
- You did it for how...
Three hours?
- Three hours after I got bit.
- With a snake bite?
- Yeah. But when I...
Then it started hurting
real bad and I was like,
"Oh. I ain't never going
to get out of this holler."
- People die from that.
- Oh yeah. I stayed in the
hospital I believe six days
but I didn't go to the ER
till like 11:00 that night.
You know?
That's what made it bad, I guess,
'cause I didn't go
straight to the hospital.
Have you ever ginsenged?
- I have never ginsenged.
- You ought to go make
your show about that.
(Sue laughing)
- So what do you think of
the future of this region?
It seems like the drugs have taken over
the younger generation.
- Yeah, it really has.
I mean, people used to smoke pot.
A lot of people thinks pot's real bad.
I don't see it is.
My uncle was an outlaw
till he started smoking pot.
When he started smoking pot
he turned into a peaceful,
quiet, worked all the time...
I mean he'd eat a lot
and he'd got the munchies
and just chilled out.
But then, when that
meth have come in here,
it's destroyed the whole...
It really has destroyed the whole area
which it's everywhere you know,
but I've lost so many friends to drugs.
Everybody's on something.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah. Is that something
you struggled with as well?
- Not now, but in past. Yeah, once,
but it wasn't meth was mine.
I got on...
When my pappaw died
I got on nerve pills real bad.
And that was my...
But I got off of them
and my boy got killed three
year ago on a four wheeler.
- I'm sorry.
And they've tried to give me Xanax
but I just won't go get 'em.
'cause I know...
You know what I'm saying?
I don't wanna be back on them
'cause they're the best pill
and they're the worst
pill that ever was made.
But mostly around here
it's just meth or...
Used to everybody drunk and got drunk
and it was alcohol and maybe pot.
Then, it went to meth and stuff like that,
which heroin and stuff like that
really ain't in this
part of the country bad.
- What do you think of the
future for people here?
'Cause drugs have taken over and...
- Buddy, if they don't start
putting some kind of business
like work here, the little
kids ain't got no hope
in this part of the...
They ain't 'cause a lot
of people don't know about
how to make money in
the mountains and stuff.
They just...
There ain't no way of surviving, you know.
What you gonna do?
And they have to depend on a food stamp
or government assistance 'cause...
Or their kids would starve to death.
You know what I mean?
I was raised in this holler
or it was up Trace
Branch I was telling you
but up in there everybody
raised their own garden,
but well...
He was our neighbor,
but he was like afraid
of the world or the law.
So he built him a little tar shack.
It had a little dirt floor
and all he had in there
was a little bed and a stove.
And I mean, he was happy with that.
You know what I mean?
You could build him a mansion
and he wouldn't have lived in it.
- A lot of people I've...
- He was like...
He loved his little tar shack I guess.
- I've seen and I've met
a lot of people here now.
And it seems like they live
a very, very simple life
- Yes.
- but they're also very happy.
- Yeah. When we was growing
up, that's when FNS,
like all these interns would come in
and they would...
All them nurses and
stuff would get together.
My uncles and all them,
they had a bluegrass band.
So they would play music
with our square dances
like every Saturday night
and we made a lot of friends
through that.
Like one was Holly Cheever.
She's a veterinarian now in New York.
But we had, on Saturday nights
you had that to look forward to.
Then we started going to the wrestling.
We would do that every weekend.
And that was fun, but it was just...
Life was sweet and simple, I guess.
My grandma, my great-grandma right now,
she's buried right in
the top of a mountain
in an old hill road that used to,
they used as a road, like, travel it.
See, she would go around
and deliver babies.
These old timers, when
they had their babies
there weren't no nurses.
That was for Mary Breckinridge.
So, she was a granny
woman and they called her
and pappaw said sometimes
four in the morning,
somebody would come,
you're gonna have to come,
let's see, so-and-so's in labor
and she would get on her old mule
and hit them old mountain roads
that takes you from one holler to the next
and deliver a baby, you know.
That was probably, that
was my great grandma.
And they was like the
first settlers really,
like upstanding.
Like Hugh Morgan, them ole Morgans.
There was a bunch of them, but...
Then, like in Trace Branch,
we didn't have a well,
so we would...
They'd take like a horse and a sled
and my uncle Albert would go around,
digging them dug wells for everybody,
but we didn't have one.
So, we'll go to the
neighbors and get water,
fill these big cans up in the sled.
And I remember riding in
the back of that sled,
I loved that but that's how
we got our water till...
Well, we got a well drilled
probably when I was 12 year old
or probably 10, but...
And we was probably one of the first ones
to even have a drilled well in the holler
'cause they didn't have electricity
till probably the late 50s.
And the man lived on Rock House is...
He was the one put a
road through that holler.
So, you know, they didn't have no road.
They traveled the creek beds
and these old mountain roads.
My mammaw's buried right
in the middle of one
of them old mountain roads right now.
- That's a very special
part of the country.
- Oh yeah. It's real special.
I'd like to go show you where I was raised
and see how...
You talk about beautiful
but it is beautiful up in there.
- Yeah.
- It's got the falls.
I mean it's, it's so beautiful.
Everybody thinks it's beautiful.
I mean, it is, and we would...
Oh, when it snowed, oh, that was...
We didn't care if it
stayed all year round then
'cause you didn't have
no school, you know?
And we would get out at
daylight on them ole sleds
and it would get so
cold, we'd build fires up
and warm our feet up by the fire.
- What's your favorite
memory in your life?
- My grandpa, I guess and my grandma.
They was raised...
They didn't have electric.
She raised 12 kids by
the sweat of her brow.
She growed everything they
eat, put it away in the fall.
She had a milk cow that
she got up every morning
at five o'clock and probably walked a mile
just to milk the cow.
And she done that twice a day
'cause pappaw worked making mining props
and they didn't get paid
probably 50 cents a week.
You know what I'm saying?
He didn't get nothing hardly
and the only thing they
got out of the store
would be like sugar,
'cause she made her own
grease; her own lard.
Well, they raised hogs, killed the hogs.
Every winter, they would take turns,
like two or three different families
would have a hog to kill.
This one would go up with
that one and kill their hog.
Then the other one
would help the other one
and they'd all share the meat
and had smoke houses.
I'd like for...
Some people's doing that right now
like living off the grid.
I'd really like to do that.
I mean, when I was little,
I was little then but
I remember how it was.
I'd follow him to milk the cows.
Now I won't drink cow milk
probably just off the tit,
you know what I'm saying?
But then, that's all we had to drink.
- Do you have any regrets?
- Yeah, I regret quitting school. Yeah.
- Yeah.
What's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Well, you can get in
trouble real easy so...
I learned my lesson, but
I really can't explain it.
Trying to, I mean...
A lesson learned is like
getting out with your friends
that you think is your big
buddies that can get you
to do stuff you wouldn't normally do.
And then, my lesson learned is
they ain't always your
friends, that try...
They're not your friend
that tries to get you
to do stuff like that.
Do good in life. Go for what's right.
And be good.
- All right. Sue, thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- Good luck. Good luck in mountains.
(Sue laughing)
- You'll have to go with us some time.
- I'd like that. Thank you.
- Yeah, you give me your number
and I'll find you some good'ens.